hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester we are back with three
days of rapid in two days of Blitz
it's the Tata Steel India edition the
rapid and blitz the tournament is being
played in the national library of India
in Kolkata and it's Magnus cross and
versus Yana phone machine
now before we check out the game I would
just like to mention for those of you
who have been following the channel for
quite some time not so long ago okay
maybe some six months ago I mentioned
that we will be doing a chess manga and
that for those of you who are interested
that I will keep you posted and then you
sent me a lot of your emails with ideas
for the manga well we are now
well we we're almost ready to take it
forward but we need the help of wealth
of a writer so if any of you is a writer
or if any of you has a wealth tendency
to writing do contact us on the the
email that will be provided below it's a
matter manga at gmail.com but you can
also just copy it it will be the first
thing you've seen the description below
so that being said let's check it out
here we have a very nice photo photo is
by Leonard Otis official photographer of
the Grantchester here are all the
participants just to get to know who's
who's playing
we have neppo here 11 our onion magnus
carlsen he Cara Nakamura Wesley so
viswanathan anand ding li Ren and if
hearing those are the standard
Grantchester players and the two
wildcards are with it and Hari Krishna
so that being said and well it's it you
know I don't know who's gonna win the
tournament but it's pretty obvious who
won the the photo here we can even make
him a bit larger look at that nipple
like a boss seems like he heard I said
in one of my videos that there are very
few good photos of neppo and ever since
then all of all of his photos are just
amazing so there you have it we can make
him smaller now
and before we check out the game I would
just also like to mention that Dee this
is the record between Magnus and the
Napo before this game so it's no no
mystery that neppo has a brilliant score
against Magnus in classical chest you
can see in classical games neppo beat
Magnus four to one with six draws but
when it comes to rapid as you can see
below
rapid and exhibition games to Magnus
beat Nepal 5 to 0 with a draw so
although neppo is one of the few that
can take on Magnus in the classical time
section in rapid and Magnus has a 5 to 0
so as this is a rapid game now let's see
what happens here
Magnus with the white pieces opened with
e4 we have c5 nipple goes for the
Sicilian defense Knight f3 d6 and we
have Bishop to b5 check the canal attack
Knight to d7 blocking in the now d4 we
have seek after sandy for not night but
Queen captures on d4 Enda now a6 pushing
the bishop back Bishop to e2 and now
Knight G to f6 now we have castles by
white and now II five attacking the
Queen we have Queen back to III and not
nice the c5 all this has been played
before and mangas goes for Knight f2 d2
preparing to push the F pawn and while
you could do it with Knight c3 the
Guardi for pondan Knight g4 could be
somewhat of a problem harassing the
Queen and after the Queen moves now we
just repeat attack at the phone again
maybe you could maybe draw white into
accepting an early draw or or make what
a white to waste more Tempe with the
Bishop to d3 so it's hard to say but
Knight f2 d2 is the usual move here we
have b5 by neppo and the now c4 just
further expanding with B captures on c4
and now there is one game where Bishop
characters and c4 was played but here
Knights the c3 by crossing and it is as
a move 11 that we have a completely new
game on our hands so the game continues
Bishop to b7 never develops with Bishop
captures on c4 and now Bishop to e7 and
neppo is already the castle now we have
before pushing the knight back Knights
the e6 now with ideas of going to d4 or
f4 depending on wall boy place and the
knight the b3 just taking care of the d4
square we have ripped the c8 now
pressuring the bishop on c4 and Knight
to a5 defending it and there is no easy
way to get get hold of this night so
it's not a problem that night although
under on the edge of the board will
guard the bishop nicely we have Queen to
d7 here Neville is ready to castle but
here
who wants to play Bishop to dh2 get rid
of the knight so Queen to d3 adding
another defender to the bishop and now
comes Castle it's not a problem you
don't have to worry about losing the a6
pawn because the knight on c3 would also
be hanging so Bishop to e3
Magnus continuous development and the
now Bishop to d8 we're putting pressure
on the knight on a five finally Knight
captures an b7 by Magnus Queen captures
in the now Knight to d5 and excellent
square for the knight but Nippo first
goes Knight to c7 now he's ready to do a
lot of trades on the d5 square so Knight
captures on f6 with check and Bishop
captures and now rook a to be one here
the material on the board is equal but
Magnus has a two-to-one advantage on the
Queen side he's ready to push a 4 and b5
to create a passed pawn on the Queen
side we have rook F to d8 by napal napal
would very much enjoy pushing d5 if
possible we did have the Sicilian after
all and rook F the d1 adding another a
piece to control the D file with h6
creating some room for the King and f3
now strengthening the center we have
Queen to c6 now putting pressure on the
bishop after the knight moves there will
be a queen Bishop battery here along the
C file and now Queen the b3 putting
pressure on the f7 pawn here and here
Queen back to e 8 guarding the pawn with
a 4 by Magnus now ready to put b5 to
create a passed pawn on the Queen side
and now rook to b8 that doesn't really
stop be 5 so Magnus advances it we have
b5 a captures a captures in the now 96
we have
b6 advancing the point even further and
the now comes Bishop to g5 hoping to
trade off this very strong dark square
bishop that defends the b6 pawn Magnus
declines and here you don't really have
a good way of countering whites whites
ideas on the Queen side was just gonna
play rook the a1 bring the other rook
over to b1 get the bishop to d5 control
the a square exchange rooks at some
point well maybe even double rooks on
the a file it's hard to say so here
nipple sacrifice is a Ponte you know to
muddy the waters a bit so to say
we're Magnus except with Bishop captures
pawn captures rook captures and here
nipple goes Rudy to c8 and here nipple
really tries to trick Magnus because
well it's not well it's somewhat simple
because you're all for the second pawn
but if you would like to you know
practice calculating a bit what's the
idea behind real captures on d6 is it
possible or what what snipers idea if
Magnus captures the pawn try to figure
out while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
that congratulations on finding such a
sneaky idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show if rook
captures here then Nepos idea was Bishop
to e7 now obviously you have to move the
rook if you don't want to be down at
least the exchange and after the rook
moves now you pick up the phone and b6
and now the point is you cannot capture
because Bishop to c5 check wins the
Queen that was an episode eeeh but
Magnus is not very impressed he simply
pushes b7 attacks the rockin c8 we have
worked the c5 and Bishop to d5 now
cementing his position here that you are
not touching this pawn it's on a light
square black only has a dark square
bishop there are no Knight so unless you
want to give up the exchange that pawn
is staying there forever we have Queen
to e7 by nepo and then outlook the c4
now Magnus wants to trade down as much
as possible because the pawn on b7 is a
winning pawn we have Queen to c7 now
Magnus straight once rook captures pawn
captures creating a pass bond of his own
and now g3 preparing f4 and E 5 to
completely shut down the dark square
bishop we have Bishop to f6 by neppo and
now comes King to g2 just slowly
improving the position there is no rush
no one is touching that pawn we have
Queen back the e7 by neppo and now Queen
to b6 we have Bishop to e5 now guarding
the the rook here and the just Queen to
see 6 at some point you want to push f4
e 5 and go Quinta CA to check but and
not not while the Bishop guards the rook
here so we have King to h7 not all
this come with check if at any point
play played so f4 attacking the bishop
and now you could go bash up somewhere
back but then rook the c1 will be very
strong you you're gonna lose the c5 pawn
so here nepo is forced to put the bishop
behind the pawn but now comes Queen the
CA and okay it's not with check so it's
not that big of a deal
Queen to d6 you cannot capture of course
because you're white just gets another
Queen entire game so Queen to d6 adding
a defender to the rook and now Queen the
f5 width check now with King to a trade
and only now pink the h3 improving the
position even more because neppo is
without a move here we have Queen a6 by
nepo and now comes a five just shutting
down the bishop even further we and well
yes it was at this point unmoved 44 that
young pony she resigned the game because
here black is without a move you there's
nothing you can do white wasn't in a
rush to push anything you can just win
this pawn which is which is perfectly
enough for when I mean the past be pond
is already enough for a win but whatever
you play let's say c4 just win captures
on f7 you're gonna push c3 but then what
what else can you play here if going to
c7 attacking the rook and on this square
there is not much you can do
you could try to defend it but well
whatever you do either you guard with
the bishop and then you lose the c3 pawn
or if if Queen Taysom then you can just
deliver Queen the ch-check like if this
was your queen to ch-check now you
cannot trade because white just gets
another Queen into the game and if King
h7 then Bishop the e4 check will be
deadly g6 now Queen the c7 check King
has to move on our Bishop captures and
g6 and black is getting made there's no
way around this so of course nepo knows
this after E 5 he resigns the game and
an excellent victory for Magnus Carlsen
in round 2 of the Tata Steel rap
tournament in India Kolkata yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
first game will be showing and we will
be covering the entire event
how many games per day but I will try as
many as possible
like I said if any of you are writers or
are interested in writing or have a lot
of spare time you know and are you know
have a interest in writing do contact us
on organ matter manga at gmail.com it
will be the first thing you see in the
description below so if you want to be a
part of our upcoming chest manga it
would be nice if you contacted us yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank David David Gill
and David lip for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos er thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester are continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and so on
until we decide on our next big saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day